morning we have new information on the
special prosecutor assigned to the Ahmad
our Barry case the unarmed black man was
chased and shot down while running
through a Georgia neighborhood he was
jogging at the time Omar Villafranca is
following this investigation
Omar good to see you what can you tell
us about this new special prosecutor
well good morning the new prosecutor was
appointed by the Georgia Attorney
General and keep in mind the US Justice
Department is also taking a look at this
case in Georgia the mod are buried death
investigation will be handled by the
Cobb County DA joy at homes she's led
the DA's office since July as she's been
both a prosecutor and a defense attorney
her appointment comes after two
prosecutors recused themselves citing
conflicts of interest involving one of
the suspects Gregory McMichael a third
asked to be removed from the case now
we've got some new video to show you
this surveillance video newly obtained
by CBS News shows our burry inside a
home that was under construction before
the shooting he looks around and then
after a few minutes leaves now the
homeowner released a statement through
their attorney which reads in part
nothing was ever stolen from the house
they were shocked and deeply saddened by
these events our buries family says he
was out for a jog on February 23rd
Gregory McMichael and his son Travis
told police our burry was a burglary
suspect and they chased him with guns
now Georgia's Attorney General says that
they will present this evidence to a
grand jury but the earliest that could
happen will be mid-june Anthony all
right Omar thank you